[Applause]
welcome back y'all our next guest
started nursing school then quick to
follow his passion of budoir Photography
then he started uploading comedy posts
during the pandemic and basically blew
up here's a look get up it's time to do
farm chores good morning good morning
damn it's hot out here my fanger nail is
sweating trick me up again and I'mma
turn your ass into bacon
bit y'all stink this is not the Winter
Olympics get off the damn Barn keep on
when you ask is it a little damn chick
nugget I don't want to hear it you won't
even make it the damn chickf honey I
take you to
McDonald he's now he's now got nearly 4
and a half million followers on Tik Tok
and he's touring the country you can
find info for his win that thing gets a
thing and tour online but please say
hello to Matt Matthews
[Music]
everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
what's up girl I can't breathe oh my God
wait what I got spanks on oh my God I
just now don't have to wear them look I
went back to come on here looking like a
busted can of biscuits you look right
and tight biscuits I was like I can't
look left and loose oh my God I left and
loose so wait I have to know this is a
random life of you had so you you
journeyed from nursing to photography to
Comedy yeah
what how did we get there child what
kind of things were involved let me tell
you something nursing wasn't for me
because I realized that that's not
Grace's
Anatomy so I said baby I can't do it I
was like wait this is not for me it's
not for me so I had to drop out yeah
okay um and then I started budoir
photography because I wanted people to
realize that it wasn't your weight that
determined your self worth yeah and I
never loved my body growing up my mom
never loved her body growing up so I
never saw body positivity oh man and so
I wanted to make people feel beautiful
and so I embarked on this journey as a
budoir photographer and it has been one
of the most incredible careers that I
could have ever had love but I always
loved entertainment and I always wanted
to make people laugh and entertain
people and yeah everybody's like baby
you need to be a comedian I said I don't
want to do that I don't know how to do
that I don't I don't have no desire to
do standup I never watch stand up it was
never something that I wanted to do and
so finally I was like let's give it a
shot yeah and it it popped off is this
because of do you think because the
pandemic kind of put you in this like
weird place where everybody kind of was
and then because you went on Tik Tok why
Tik Tok I didn't even want a Tik Tok
okay everybody's like you got to get a
Tik Tok I'm like I'm too old for Tik Tok
it's like people dancing and lips and
you know I was like No And so my best
friend was like you're ridiculous you
literally take care of your animals and
you cuss them out in a row in a row I
said baby laundry detergent too
expensive I'm not I'm not changing all
these clothes so I'm just going to wear
my robes cuz you'll run them yeah yeah
so I just wear my bath robes to take
care of them absolutely and you know
people were just like it made me laugh
this is a time that I've never you know
like it's a really really dark time in
the world yeah and for people to laugh
and feel good was just like made me feel
incredible oh my God no I get it I love
standup I watch so much stand up I love
to laugh so what is your least favorite
Farm chore grow that chicken
dooooo I can't you kept it so d time K
well you I could be on here saying you
want me I love it no no I love so you
don't like that it's a lot chicken poop
a lot L and I got like four rabbits yeah
yeah so it's too much it's a lot you
want somebody else to do that you're
like I want to make enough money if
somebody else is doing the chicken know
like I enjoy my animals they're my
escape cuz I don't like people yeah so
you know like it is my way to to I love
animals too yeah yeah yeah it's my way
to get home and enjoy you know the
silence and the you know I agree they
can't Peck you though they'll get
they'll get you and they'll go to
KFC so wait where did the name of the
tour come from cuz it's quite the title
where did that come from you really want
to know yes okay so I was doing my
chores okay and I was in my robe and I
didn't had no draws on okay and I was
twerking was it Breezy and I was
twerking and I went to pick up a bell of
hay and I was just a twerking and like
singing my song and my best friend gets
my camera out and she starts filming me
she's like you're so ridiculous and I
said girl when this thing gets a sanging
and she was like and so I was like okay
that's the name of the tour oh my God I
love I love that that's how you came up
with the name yeah all right we have to
do a commercial break Matt's standup
tour is amazing and it's called win that
thing get to thing in and now we know
where it came from so go with that go
online also for more info on cities and
[Music]
dates
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home